Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to this edition of The Rest Is History, or perhaps that should be The Rest Is Regional History, because today we want to look at the local. And Dominic, because you and I are English, we're going to focus on the regional history of England. So where do the Sandbrooks hail from? That sounds kind of very Hobbit name. I think the Sandbrooks actually come from West Wales,
感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest Is History）。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听本期《历史的剩余》，或者也许应该叫作《区域历史的剩余》，因为今天我们要关注的是本土地方史。多米尼克，因为你和我都是英格兰人，所以我们将聚焦于英格兰的区域历史。那么桑德布鲁克（Sandbrooks）家族是从哪里发迹的呢？听起来像是个非常哈比特的名字。我想桑德布鲁克家族其实来自西威尔士，
originally, in the sort of mists of time. But I'm a Shropshire, I'm a Shropshire lad. I'm like a character from A.E. Houseman. So you're a Midlander? Yeah, I'm a Midlander. My mum's family came from Wolverhampton, from Bilston in the Black Country. And I suppose that is my eye, So you're you're much more a man of the people than I am obviously because I bear the whiff of southern
最初是在时间的迷雾中。但我是一个什罗普郡人，我是个什罗普郡男孩。我就像是 A.E. 豪斯曼（A.E. Housman）笔下的角色。所以你是个米德兰兹（Midlands）人？对，我是米德兰兹人。我妈妈的家族来自伍尔弗汉普顿，来自黑乡（Black Country）的比尔斯顿。我想这就是我的视角，所以你显然比我更像一个平民，因为我身上带有南方特权的
privilege even though the Hollands actually originate from Stoke and we migrated via Birmingham to Salisbury in the heart of Wessex. My mother's family is from the Isle of Wight. I now live in London. So we've basically got the southern half of England covered, haven't we? I was about to say, you're a complete southerner, aren't you? Basically, yes. So we need a bit of northern pride. We do, a bit of grit. Yeah. So who have we got with us, Dominic? We have got Dan Jackson, the author of The Brilliant, The Northumbrian. So he is Mr. Northeastern History. And Dan, I think your claim to fame above all else is that you were the official historical advisor to Cheryl Cole.
气息，尽管霍兰（Holland）家族其实起源于特伦特河畔斯托克，我们经由伯明瀚迁移到了威塞克斯（Wessex）腹地的索尔兹伯里。我母亲的家族来自怀特岛。我现在住在伦敦。所以我们基本上把英格兰的南部给全包了，对吧？我正想说，你是个彻头彻尾的南方人，不是吗？基本上是的。所以我们需要一点北方的骄傲。没错，需要一点硬气。好吧，那我们请到了谁呢，多米尼克？我们请到了丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson），《卓越的诺森布里亚人》（The Northumbrian）一书的作者。所以他就是东北部历史先生。丹，我认为你最著名的成就是你曾担任谢丽尔·科尔（Cheryl Cole）的官方历史顾问。
Is that right? This is true. Yes. We explored Cheryl's family history in North Shield's register office. A bit of on-screen chemistry. You can still see it on YouTube. Is that how she describes it as well? We didn't keep in touch, sadly. But so, Dan, your book Northumbrians makes a kind of brilliant case,
是这样吗？千真万确。是的。我们在北谢尔兹（North Shields）的户籍办公室探讨了谢丽尔的家族史。还有点银幕化学反应。你依然可以在 YouTube 上看到。她也是这么形容的吗？遗憾的是，我们没有保持联系。不过，丹，你的书《诺森布里亚人》提出了一个极妙的观点，
not just for the significance of Northumbria, but generally, I think, regional history that we can learn a lot from looking at the various parts of a country as well as country as a whole. And I guess that one of the things you get again and again, not just in England, but in Scotland, in Ireland, in France, in Italy, in America, pretty much anywhere you want to look at is the idea of a north-south divide. And perhaps we could kind of focus on that and just cut Dominic out completely. We don't need to bother with the Midlands. He's been itching for this for weeks. So to kick things off, we've got a question from Kane kane carlisle um probably one to cause some
不仅证明了诺森布里亚的重要性，而且一般而言，我认为区域历史能让我们从国家各个不同部分以及整体国家中获益良多。我想你不仅在英格兰，在苏格兰、爱尔兰、法国、意大利、美国，几乎在你想看的任何地方，都会不断听到的一种观点就是南北差距。也许我们可以把焦点放在这上面，完全把多米尼克晾在一边。我们不用管米德兰兹。他为此已经手痒好几个星期了。所以为了开个好头，我们有一个来自凯恩·卡莱尔（Kane Carlisle）的问题，嗯，这可能会引发
controversial debate and that's good because obviously we want controversial debate but where would you argue the line between north and south should be drawn in england that is not in great britain in england well with my northumbrian perspective, specifically a Tyneside perspective to this, I think there is a case to be made that anywhere south of Scotch Corner is basically a wasteland of warm beer and Morris dancing. But I think there's a good case to be made for the Mersey-Humber line, basically, in England. And there are some border counties along there that it's debatable about which side of the line they should fit in, particularly Derbyshire and Nottinghamshire. But basically, I think in English history,
争议性的辩论，这很好，因为我们显然希望有争议性的辩论，但你认为在英格兰——注意，不是在大不列颠，而是在英格兰——北方和南方的分界线应该划在哪里？好吧，以我的诺森布里亚视角，具体来说是泰恩赛德（Tyneside）的视角，我认为有理由认为：苏格兰角（Scotch Corner）以南的任何地方，基本上都是温啤酒和莫里斯舞（Morris dancing）的不毛之地。但我认为，在英格兰，以默西-亨伯（Mersey-Humber）一线作为分界线是很有道理的。沿线有一些边界郡，它们究竟该属于这条线的哪一边还存有争议，特别是德比郡和诺丁汉郡。但基本上，我认为在英国历史上，
the topographical barriers within England still aren't well enough understood. And, you know, rivers, hills, forests were difficult to get through, were difficult to traverse for a long time. And if you just, if you think about the geography of England, if you think about the Mersey and the mosses of South Lancashire, you've probably heard of Moss Side in Manchester. Mosses were sort of marshes, difficult to get through. Then that kind of led into the Peak District again, you know, quite a formidable range of hills to get across. Then you've got the
英格兰内部的地形屏障至今仍未得到足够的了解。而且，你知道，河流、山丘、森林在很长一段时间里都是难以逾越、难以通行的。如果你去想一想英格兰的地理，想想默西河和南兰开夏郡的沼泽（mosses）——你可能听说过曼彻斯特的莫斯赛德（Moss Side）。所谓的“沼泽”就是泥沼，很难通过。然后这又通向峰区（Peak District），再次，你知道，这是一座相当令人生畏的山脉，很难翻越。然后你还有
Sherwood Forest, which is the sort of Ardennes of England. It was difficult to get through as well. And then you've got the Trent and the Humber. And the Severn Trent line, some people often pick that out as a key dividing line in England, I think is important but I think the most durable boundary the dividing north and south is that sort of straggly line from the Mersey to the Humber which is difficult to get through and I think it's interesting that one of the few passes through there is a place called Door outside Sheffield literally a door you know an entrance where that you could get through and though the lines either side of that boundary, which roughly correspond still to this day to the provinces of Canterbury and York, and to an extent, the kind of Britannia inferior and Britannia superior division of England by the
舍伍德森林（Sherwood Forest），它有点像是英格兰的阿登森林。它同样很难通过。然后你还有特伦特河和亨伯河。塞文-特伦特（Severn Trent）一线，有些人经常把它挑出来作为英格兰的关键分界线，我认为这很重要，但我认为分隔南北最持久的边界是默西河到亨伯河那条曲折的路线，那是很难通过的。而且我认为很有趣的是，其中一个少数的通道是一个叫做“多尔”（Door，意为“门”）的地方，在谢菲尔德郊外，字面意思就是一扇门，你知道，一个你可以穿过去的入口。尽管这条边界两侧的线条，直到今天大致仍与坎特伯雷和约克的教省相对应，并在某种程度上与
Romans. I think that's a decent starting point, to be honest. So Dan, you think it's basically, you genuinely think it's a geographical thing rather than, I mean, obviously, there's cultural and economic elements and all the rest of it, but you think that the geography comes first before the other stuff? Yeah, I'm a bit of a geographical determinist on this front, because I think that then shaped the culture that grew up on either side of that boundary. You could also explore things like the geology that was different on either side, either ends of England, the sort of upland farming country of the north, which was all pastoral. Then you had the richer, more fertile lands of the south, which are largely arable and so on. And then you've got the proximity to the prosperous core of Europe, which was an advantage that the south of England had as well. And I haven't read James Hoare's recent book on the history of England. I was kind of red-pilled a little bit, as I think the young people say, about that, the persistence of the
罗马人对英格兰进行的“下不列颠”（Britannia inferior）和“上不列颠”（Britannia superior）的划分相对应。说实话，我觉得这是一个不错的起点。所以，丹，你认为这基本上、你真心认为这是一个地理问题，而不是——我的意思是，显然有文化和经济等各方面的因素，但你认为地理因素在其他因素之前？是的，在这方面我有点地理决定论倾向，因为我认为这塑造了该边界两侧滋养出的文化。你还可以探讨其他方面，比如英格兰两端不同的地质，北方属于丘陵牧业区，全都是畜牧业。然后南方拥有更富饶、更肥沃的土地，主要是耕地等等。然后你拥有临近欧洲繁荣核心区的优势，这也是英格兰南部所具备的优势。我没有读过詹姆斯·霍尔（James Hoare）最近关于英格兰历史的书。对于英格兰历史中南北差距的持续存在，我有点被“洗脑”了，就像年轻人常说的那样。我们或许会谈到这背后的政治。不过，是的，我想这就是我的分界线。
north-south divide in English history. And we might come on to the politics of that. But yeah, I think that would be my dividing line. Well, I mean, talking about the politics and the way that that has expressed itself throughout time, since there are three of us, and since I come from the South, Dominic comes from the Midlands, and you come from the North, and the famous tripartite division
好吧，我的意思是，谈到政治以及它随着时间推移的表达方式，既然我们有三个人，而且我来自南方，多米尼克来自米德兰兹，你来自北方，而盎格鲁-撒克逊时期著名的三分法
in the Anglo-Saxon period is between Wessex and Mercia and Lothumbria, it might be good to introduce them at this stage. Because of course, the dividing line that you highlight between the Humber and the Mersey is what formed the fusion of Wessex and Mercia in the wake of Alfred the Great's reign, and then his son, Edward. And then Edward's son, Athelstan, he advances from the Mersey-Humber line and conquers Northumbria. And that essentially is then what constitutes England, the United Kingdom of England. The union, perhaps, of those three kingdoms, plus East Anglia. So good to get them in early and good, obviously, to get Athelstan in.
是在威塞克斯、麦西亚（Mercia）和诺森布里亚之间，在这个阶段把它们引入进来也许是个好主意。因为当然，你强调的亨伯河和默西河之间的分界线，正是阿尔弗雷德大王统治之后及其子爱德华统治期间，威塞克斯和麦西亚融合的产物。然后爱德华的儿子埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）从默西-亨伯一线挺进并征服了诺森布里亚。这基本上就构成了英格兰，即英格兰联合王国。或许是这三个王国加上东盎格利亚的联合。所以很庆幸能早点提到它们，而且显然也很庆幸能提到埃塞尔斯坦。
I think he gets his first mention of the series, doesn't he? He does. Well done, Tom. Can I just ask a question now that you've brought that up, the Anglo-Saxons? Dan, what about the Dane law? Do you think the Dane law is a big thing? Do you think that's an enduring boundary? I think it is, yeah. Although it's slightly different from my perspective, again, right up in the northeast of England, because the the the danes um certainly raided but did not
我想这是他在本系列中第一次被提及，对吧？是的。干得好，汤姆。既然你已经提到了盎格鲁-撒克逊人，我能问个问题吗？丹，关于丹麦区（Danelaw）呢？你认为丹麦区是一件大事吗？你认为那是一个持久的边界吗？我认为是的，没错。尽管从我的角度来看略有不同，再次强调，是在英格兰的极东北部，因为丹麦人
settle north of the teas and i've always been very interested in the lands between the teas and the tweed as in my view forming a separate entity basically in english history and it was always that that land was always seen as a bit of a buffer zone as well between england and scotland we haven't really touched on the northern frontier of all this, but you know, the border between England and Scotland was pretty much settled in 1018 after the Battle of Carrham on the River Tweed. So some people think it fluctuates a little bit, but actually it's been pretty stable for about a thousand years. Well, Dan, following up from that, we've got another question from Sean Barnes, and this leads in very quickly, which is,
确实进行过袭击，但并没有在蒂斯河（Tees）以北定居。我一直对蒂斯河和特威德河（Tweed）之间的土地非常感兴趣，在我看来，它们在英国历史中基本上构成了独立的存在，而且这片土地一直被视为英格兰和苏格兰之间的一块缓冲区。我们还没怎么触及这一切的北部边境，但是，你知道，英格兰和苏格兰之间的边界在1018年特威德河畔的卡拉姆战役（Battle of Carrham）之后基本上就确定了。所以有些人认为它有一点波动，但实际上大约一千年里它都相当稳定。好吧，丹，接着这个话题，我们有来自肖恩·巴恩斯（Sean Barnes）的另一个问题，这可以非常迅速地引出一个问题，那就是：
does the north of England, in other words, have more in common with Scotland than it does with the south of England that's an interesting question because of course Scotland is also a united kingdom a stitch together of many different identities and one of those identities obviously is the Northumbrian identity yeah I think so I think a useful way of looking at to an extent the useful way of looking at my Northumbria useful way of looking at um my northumbria is if you think of a venn diagram of england and scotland northumbria is a sort of shaded overlapping section because it does it does feature i mean from my point of view if you look at the similarities between cities like newcastle and glasgow and edinburgh there is there is an
英格兰北部，换句话说，是不是与苏格兰有更多的共同点，而不是与英格兰南部？这是一个有趣的问题，因为当然苏格兰也是一个联合王国，是由许多不同的身份拼凑而成的，而其中一个身份显然就是诺森布里亚身份。是的，我想是的。我认为看待这个问题的一个有用方式是，在某种程度上，看待我的诺森布里亚的一个有用方式是，如果你想象一个英格兰和苏格兰的韦恩图（Venn diagram），诺森布里亚就是那个有阴影的重叠部分，因为它的确——从我的角度来看，如果你看看纽卡斯尔、格拉斯哥和爱丁堡等城市之间的相似之处，在文化、建筑、贸易模式、这些地方的工业基础、
affinity there in culture and architecture and trading patterns in the industrial base of those places enthusiasm for football and beer and machismo and all those sorts of features which i do i do think there there is that cultural sort of um vibe that you can notice the similarities with but i mean again it goes back to um very early medieval period because the kingdom of northumbria really goes right the way up to to where edinburgh is now it does yes and there are some of us with kind of revanchist divide her designs on the lines of the fourth um but um but yeah the but that that that anglo-scottish border was border was much fought over and it was slightly complicated too by
对足球和啤酒的热情、大男子主义以及所有这些特征方面，确实存在一种契合，我确实认为那种文化氛围、那种你可以察觉到相似之处的共鸣是存在的。但我的意思是，这又回到了中世纪早期，因为诺森布里亚王国实际上一直延伸到现在的爱丁堡所在的地方。确实如此，是的。我们当中有些人对福斯湾（Forth）一带抱有某种收复失地主义的划分构想，但是，但是，是的，英格兰和苏格兰之间的边界曾饱受争夺，而且情况也稍微有些复杂，因为
the kings of Scotland held Tyndale as one of their liberties as well as Huntingdonshire, didn't they? That was one of their possessions in England. As far south as Huntingdonshire, that's interesting. Yeah, there was Dr Francis Young wrote an interesting thing
苏格兰国王曾将蒂ndale（泰恩代尔）作为他们的自治领地之一，亨廷顿郡（Huntingdonshire）也是如此，不是吗？那是他们在英格兰的领地之一。远至亨廷顿郡，这很有趣。是的，弗朗西斯·杨（Francis Young）博士最近对此写过一篇有趣的文章，探讨从技术上讲亨廷顿郡是否仍然是苏格兰的一部分。这得去问尼古拉斯·德吉恩特（Nicholas Durgent）。丹，让我再就上一个问题盘问你一点点，因为我在你一开始讲话时就突然想到，强调北方和南方的不同在某种程度上有点粉碎了英格兰的概念。所以你是不是在说——
on that recently about whether technically Huntingdonshire is still part of Scotland. It's one for Nicholas Durgent. Dan, let me just quiz you a tiny bit more on that last question, because it occurred to me in your very first, when we were talking right at the beginning, that the emphasis on sort of what differentiates North and South slightly sort of explodes the idea of an England. So are you sort of saying,ates north and south slightly sort of um explodes the idea of an
英格兰的概念？所以你是不是在说——我的意思是，这个问题：“北方与苏格兰有更多共同点吗？”如果这是真的，难道东北部的人们对自己的英格兰属性不看重吗？东北部的人不是追随英格兰足球队吗？他们并没有被斯特金（Nicola Sturgeon）迷人的嗓音所诱惑，不是吗？我的意思是，他们的英格兰属性对他们而言绝对是至关重要的吧？我认为它开始变得更加重要了，这在很大程度上与足球有关，也就是96年欧洲杯（Euro 96）现象，
england so are you sort of saying i mean this question does the north have more in common with scotland if in it can that be true because surely the their englishness is very important to people in the northeast isn't it i mean northeasterners follow the england football team they're not they're not they're not sort of lured away by the siren voice of Nicola Sturgeon, are they? I mean, their Englishness surely matters to them intensely. I think it has started to matter more, largely related to football, the kind of the Euro 96 phenomenon
在那里你开始看到一种更加自信的英格兰身份。毫无疑问，英格兰史上最伟大的足球运动员当然都来自英格兰东北部。毫无疑问，当然是这样。但是比利·赖特（Billy Wright）——不，不，不，你大错特错了。但我认为我们不应该忽视这样一个事实（我自己的家庭就是这一产物的结晶）：19世纪的英格兰北部是英格兰人、苏格兰人、爱尔兰人和威尔士人的巨大熔炉，
where you started to see a more assertive English identity. And certainly England's greatest ever footballers came from the North East of England. There's no question about that, of course. But Billy Wright, no, no, no, you're greatly mistaken. But I think what we shouldn't lose sight of the fact, and my own family is a product of this, is that the north of England was a huge melting pot
因此英国身份并不是——你知道，在某些圈子里，我猜，英国身份给人一种略微令人反感的感觉。它有点像是“统治吧，不列颠尼亚”（Rule Britannia）和屠夫……本播客不这么认为。本播客不这么认为。但在某些圈子里（是这样）。但我认为，这是一个很好的描述，描绘了19世纪那种将格拉斯哥与泰恩赛德、默西赛德、巴罗因弗尼斯（Barrow-in-Furness，北兰开夏郡一个非常具有苏格兰风情的城镇）连接在一起的相互交织的工业世界。这就是事实，那里的居民融合成了一个真正的英国族群，在我看来。但我觉得你是对的，英格兰身份——所有的民调都表明这一点——正在不断增强。但我依然认为，当谈到南北方的文化、工业基础等各方面时，英格兰基本上由至少两个国家组成。
of English, Scottish, Irish and Welsh in the 19th century. So that a British identity wasn't, you know, in certain quarters, I suppose, a British identity has a slightly distasteful feel to it. It's kind of rule Britannia and the butchers. Not on this podcast. Not on this podcast. But in certain quarters. But I think it's a good description of the kind of interconnected
顺着这个话题，这可能是多米尼克绝对想插话的一个问题。它来自基思·曼斯菲尔德（Keith Mansfield）。他问：为什么北方人和南方人都忽视米德兰兹？
industrial world of the 19th century that connected Glasgow to, you know, Tyneside, Merseyside, Barrow-in-Furness was a very Scottish town in North Lancashire. That was just a fact that there was a huge melding of that population into a genuinely British population, in my view. But I think you're right that the English identity, and all the polling suggests this, is growing all the time. But I still think that England is basically two nations, at least, when it comes to North versus South in its culture, industrial base, etc, etc. Following on from that, and this might be a question that Dominic would definitely want to come in. It's from Keith Mansfield. And he says, why do people from either North or South ignore the Midlands?
确实是“#米德兰兹”。我们拥有丰富的历史而存在着。是的，他说得很对，不是吗？丹，难道我们没有在这里进行南北瓜分的嫌疑吗？是的，我想我们有。而且，你知道，从我的角度来看，我的米德兰兹基本上是 M62 高速公路走廊。兰开夏郡和约克郡对我来说就像是米德兰兹。但我想，听听多米尼克的看法会很好：米德兰兹真的和英格兰南部其他地方那么不同吗？他们有独特的……因为坦白说，我会把米德兰兹和南方归为一类。
Hashtag Midlands indeed. We exist with a rich history. Yeah, he's quite right, isn't he? Dan, are we not guilty of a kind of Southern Northern carve up here? Yeah, I think we are. And, you know, my Midlands are basically the M62 corridor from my point of view. Lancashire and Yorkshire feel like the Midlands to me. But I suppose, and it'd be good to get Dominic's take on this, that are the Midlands that different to the rest of the south of England? Do they have a distinct... because I would lump the Midlands in with the south, frankly.
太可耻了。这太可耻了。我认为米德兰兹非常独特，我认为有——我的意思是，工业革命始于什罗普郡、黑乡。丹在皱眉，因为他认为一切都始于东北部。难道不是始于韦尔德（Weald）吗？汤姆，看在上帝的份上，清醒一点吧。不，我认为米德兰兹有着非常独特的——韦尔德、米德兰兹有着独特的身份……韦尔德的铁厂？米德兰兹有着独特的身份。我的意思是，如果你想想西米德兰兹和工业，它通常建立在工程学、制链业、小型家族企业的基础上，不一定是大型工厂，而是更小型的工作坊。
That's shameful. that is shameful um i think the midlands are very distinctive i think there's i mean the industrial revolution began in shropshire black country i mean dan's frowning because he thinks everything began in the northeast did it not begin in the weald get a group of yourself tom for god's sake uh no i think the midlands has a very distinctive the weald the midlands has a distinctive identity... The eye works of the wheeled? The Midlands has a distinctive identity. I mean, if you think about the West Midlands and industry, it's often founded on engineering, on chain making, on small family-run enterprises, not necessarily big factories, but smaller workshops.
而且这里绝对有一种文化认同。我的意思是，甚至一些微小的事情，比如，你提到了足球，显然，我的意思是，足球在北方和米德兰兹的大部分地区是共享的，但当足球联赛创立时，往往是北方和米德兰兹的俱乐部。所以在某种意义上，米德兰兹感觉更偏北方；这里有独特的饮品，有独特的方言，比如你在西米德兰兹会喝的一品脱迈尔德啤酒（mild），你在南方未必会喝到。所以我觉得有——米德兰兹显然一直是这个故事里的“波斯尼亚”，不是吗？它是被贪婪的目光所觊觎的牺牲品，或者确实是被双方拒绝的受害者，双方都拒绝将米德兰兹视为另一个世界的一部分。
And there's definitely a sort of cultural identity. I mean, even tiny things like, you know, you mentioned football, obviously, I mean, football is shared across um much of the what the north and the midlands but when the football league was started it tended to be northern and midlands clubs so in that sense the midlands feels more northern um there are sort of distinctive drinks there are distinctive dialects you know a pint of mild for example that you would drink in the west midlands, you wouldn't drink necessarily in the South. So I think there are I think the Midlands has obviously been it has been it is the sort of Bosnia of this story, isn't it? It's the sort of it's the sort of the victim of the greedy eyes of or indeed the rejectionists on both sides who reject the midlands as part of the of the other world and
我想关于米德兰兹发生的另一件事是，工业的衰退意味着现在米德兰兹可能感觉比以前更偏南方了，因为你知道，在20世纪80年代初，没有哪个地方的制造业崩溃像西米德兰兹那样按比例严重。因此，在某种意义上，我猜它现在感觉可能比50年前更偏南方了。但这大概开启了一个有趣的问题：区域身份是否是一成不变的？因为丹，你在开始时提出，其中许多是由地理和地质决定的，这意味着某些区域身份感是你可以一直追溯的，
i guess the other thing that's happened with the midlands is um the decline of industry means maybe the midlands feels a little bit more southern now than it did because you know nowhere suffered a greater collapse in manufacturing in the first years of the 1980s than the west midlands did proportionately um and so in that sense, I guess it maybe feels more southern now than it would have done 50 years ago. But I guess, I mean, that kind of opens up the interesting question about whether regional identities are constant. Because Dan, at the beginning, you suggested that a lot of these are determined by geography and geology, which would imply that certain senses of regional identity are things that you can trace
你知道，也许一直追溯到罗马时期，甚至更早。但相反地，通讯越发达，地质和地理的意义就越不重要，也许这些区域身份也就越淡化。关于《诺森布里亚人》，最令人着迷的事情之一就是，你绝对证明了这是一个非常、非常强烈的区域身份。但我读这本书时的想法是，这真的是英格兰的经典范例。几乎在其他任何地方都没有这种规模的区域身份，也许利物浦算一个吧。
right the way, you know, maybe all the way back to the Roman period, perhaps even before. But conversely, the better communications become, the less significant geology and geography becomes, and perhaps the more these regional identities fade. And one of the things that is fascinating about the Northumbrians is that you absolutely make the case that this is a very, very strong regional identity. But I thought kind of reading it that it's really the classic example in England. There aren't regional identities in that scale almost anywhere else, perhaps Liverpool, I guess.
你能想到其他的吗，多米尼克？不，我认为你是对的。我认为诺森布里亚——嗯，东北部很不寻常，部分原因是因为它太远了。你不觉得那是——我的意思是，对东北部的人来说，“偏远”听起来可能具有冒犯性，因为他们会说偏远的是英格兰的其他地方。但你不认为关键在于它距离伦敦太远，以至于没有被“污染”——如果可以用这个词的话。我想 producer（制作人）提议的唯一另一个地方是——
Can you think of any other, Dominic? No, I think it's right. I think Northumbria well the North East is unusual partly because it's so far do you not think that's I mean that's the remoteness I mean remoteness would sound offensive
我要把功劳归给他，因为这是他的主意而且他说得很对，那是康沃尔（Cornwall）。所以，同样地，它们都属于边缘地带。我的意思是，它们都在边缘，不是吗？我的意思是，你觉得诺森布里亚、东北部很不寻常吗？你觉得康沃尔是一个很好的对比吗，丹？关于距离因素，你是对的。在工业全盛时期，纽卡斯尔和伦敦之间一直有一种着迷感，
for somebody in the North East because they'd say it's the rest of England that's remote but don't you think that's the key that it's so far away particularly from London that it's not been contaminated as for want of a better word. I suppose the only other place the producer is suggesting,
因为它们是英格兰人口最多、距离最远的两大中心。它们之间有一种互惠共生的关系，因为伦敦是“大烟雾”（the big smoke），因为它从1600年代开始燃烧纽卡斯尔的煤炭。它依赖于这种燃料动力来源，并且有来来往往的交通运输，这意味着纽卡斯尔作为一个省会城市，通过往来的运煤船，其连接度好得超乎寻常。随着人们意识到不再需要煤炭，这种关系略有恶化，但我——有趣的是，我们已经开始接触到西部乡村（West Country）了，因为西部乡村在其中的定位一直是个棘手的问题。我有一种隐隐的感觉，像纽卡斯尔这样地方的人、吉迪人（Geordies）在国家意识中有一个清晰的形象，
I'm going to give him the credit since it's his idea and he's quite right, it's Cornwall. So, again, they're both kind of peripheral. I mean, they're on the edge, aren't they? I mean, do you think Northumbria, the northeast, is unusual? Do you think Cornwall is a good comparison, Dan? I think you're right about the distance factor. There was always a fascination
而布里斯托尔我认为不一定有。我一直有这种直觉，这是因为他们从来没有过一支优秀的足球球队，所以他们从未像其规模所暗示的那样，在国家话语中占据那么大的分量。但是——索姆塞特郡（Somerset）的人有点代表了乡下人，不是吗？这是典型的乡村口音，当人们扮演农民或其他什么角色时，这会成为默认模式。所以，缺少足球球队可能正是关键所在，因为你需要一个大型城市群。而布里斯托尔并不与此相关。
in the industrial heyday between Newcastle and London because they were the two largest centres of English population at the furthest distance from each other. They had this reciprocal symbiotic relationship really because London is the big smoke because it started to burn Newcastle coal from the 1600s. uh it relied on that source of fuel power and there was a traffic
另一件事是，当然，我们正在谈论的——我们也许应该谈论的程度是：英格兰是一个奇特地城市化的国家，我们可能没有大多数其他国家所拥有的那种乡村空间感，因此，萨默塞特郡作为一个乡村地方的想法，其重要性就变得更加重大了。他们是我们最后的农民，不是吗？我们比大多数欧洲国家更早失去了我们的农民阶层社区，我想，而他们坚持了下来。然后还有诺福克（Norfolk），我猜还有英格兰其他不那么容易纳入北方对南方对米德兰兹这种模式的地区。他们是不是有点特立独行？好吧，有一个越来越明显的趋势，不是吗，丹？最大的分歧不是——我的意思是，我认为这越来越真实——不是北方和南方，而是伦敦与所谓“深层英格兰”之间的分歧。没错。类似于大都市和边缘地区。
backwards and forwards and it meant that newcastle you know newcastle as a provincial city was was unusually well connected through the collier ships going backwards and forwards um as that as people realized they didn't need coal anymore that relationship has soured slightly but i i it's interesting we've already we started to touch upon the west country because where the west country fits into this is always a bit of a tricky question and i've got a slight hunch that a place like newcastle has a well-drawn people from there the geordies have a well-drawn or there's a well-drawn picture of them in the national consciousness um in a way that bristol i don't think does necessarily and my i've always had this hunch it's because they've
好吧，这就把我们带到了另一个来自——我们会记得这个名字，以前出现过——Paradoximoron 的问题。哦，是的，我记得 Paradoximoron。他/她问：伦敦作为英格兰首要城市的统治地位可以追溯到多远以前？它一直都是这样的吗？我能回答这个问题吗？这太令人震惊了，他自己在自问自答。好吧，我的意思是，这可以追溯到罗马人时期——说下去，伦敦是一个罗马时期的奠基。罗马行省首府中不同寻常的一点是，那里原本并没有一个现成的聚落。最初，罗马人计划将科尔切斯特（Colchester）作为中心，因为那是当地最大部落势力的中心。但伦敦之所以崛起，是因为它同时是泰晤士河上最低的桥梁渡口，
never had a good football team and so they've never really featured as much as their size should suggest in the kind of national conversation but but some i mean somerset people kind of stand in for country people, don't they? It's the archetypal rural accent, which is what people will do as the default mode for when they're farmers or whatever. And so it may be that the lack of a football team is precisely the point, because you need a large conurbation. And Bristol isn't kind of associated with that.
而且它可以通过泰晤士河口行船，所以这再次印证了丹的观点：地理就是命运。当你在不列颠南部拥有一个统一政权时，伦敦几乎不可避免地会成为最重要的中心。这其中的印证就是，当不列颠的罗马政权崩溃、南部不列颠的政治统一体碎裂时，伦敦就走向了衰落。一旦你建立了英格兰统一王国，伦敦就像一个巨大的脓疱——大当家的时候——慢慢扩张并重新掌权。我认为你是对的。
And the other thing, of course, is that we're talking that it's something that that we should perhaps talk about is the degree to which england is is a peculiarly urban country um and we don't have the sense of kind of rural space perhaps that we you get in in most other countries and that therefore the idea of somerset say as a place that is rural comes to have all the more significance. They're our last peasants, aren't they? We lost our peasant kind of community earlier than most European countries, I suppose, and they stand. And then there's Norfolk, I suppose, as well as the other region, part of England that doesn't fit that easily into this schema, I guess,
我的意思是，我认为不仅是英格兰、不列颠乃至爱尔兰的政治史和文化史，本质上都关乎伦敦及更广泛的东南部的引力，以及你如何应对它、如何与它相处。丹，在政治上，东北部的人们在多大程度上把自己定位为伦敦以及某种——我的意思是，使用我们现在都非常熟悉的术语——“大都市精英”概念的对立面？好吧，正如我所说，我认为近来这种关系恶化了，因为我们失去了这两个地方之间的那种互惠性，我们失去了这两个地方之间的那种互惠性。我们开始将自己视为一个遥远帝国首都的蒙昧省份。如果你用长远的眼光来看待英格兰南部的统治地位，
of North versus South versus Midlands. Do they stand on a limb a little bit? Well, there's an increasing thing, isn't there, Dan, that the big divide is not, I mean, I think this is increasingly true. It's not North and South, it's London versus, as it were, deep England. Right. Sort of metropolis and periphery. Okay, so this brings us on um to another
我想你可以从中解读出伦敦的统治地位。它在历史上多次击退了对其权力的任何威胁，或者坦白说，它们一直是攻击北方的跳板。你知道，如果你退后一步思考，你知道，我一直对11世纪诺曼人对北方的哈里ング（哈里森/哈里奇/哈里ing？应指哈里丁掠夺/Harrying of the North）感兴趣，然后你有了之后的玫瑰战争、宗教改革（当时北方是天主教的堡垒）、内战具有南北维度、詹姆斯党起义，然后你还有
question from we'll remember this from previously uh Paradoximoron we oh yes I remember Paradoximoron and he or she asks how far back does the dominance of London as England's premier city go was it always this way um can I answer that that's shocking he's asking and answering questions himself well i mean it goes back to the romans because go on london is a is a roman foundation what is unusual about london um among roman provincial capitals is that there wasn't a foundation there already. To begin with, the Romans planned to make Colchester the centre because that's the centre of the local largest tribal power. But London emerges because it is simultaneously the lowest bridging point on the Thames
彼得卢屠杀（Peterloo）和宪章运动起义以及所有这些在北方酝酿但被相当迅速地处理和镇压的事情。而且，你知道，从2021年的视角来看，伦敦和东南部一如既往地统治着，它击退了任何对其统治地位的威胁。而且坦白说，我看不出这方面会有什么大改变。因为从某种意义上说，无论你把多少政府部门、博物馆或其他什么东西搬到全国其他地方，一个残酷的地理现实是——我想还有几个世纪以来政治和文化力量累积效应的文化现实——使得伦敦具有如此具有挑战性的压倒性优势。
and it's navigable up the Thames estuary and so it again it illustrates Dan's point that geography is destiny and it's almost inevitable I think that when you have a unitary power in southern Britain London almost inevitably becomes the most significant centre and the measure of that is that when Roman power collapses in Britannia and the political unity in southern Britain fragments, London goes into decline. Once you have the establishment of a unitary kingdom of England, London, like a massive great spot, the great when, slowly expands and comes back into power. And I think that you're right.
是的，是的。从大约1700年到1914年，曾有过一个相对短暂的时期，当时北方在英格兰几乎占据了统治地位，因为——再次回到地质学——它在脚下发现了巨大的矿产财富。而且，你知道，像英格兰东北部这样地方的纽卡斯尔，变成了18世纪的达拉斯或迪拜，因为它控制了这种极其重要的商品——煤炭燃料动力。但这并没有持续下去。你知道，曼彻斯特同样是工业革命的中心、棉纺织业的中心以及所有这一切。
I mean, I think that essentially the political history, cultural history of not just England, but of Britain and perhaps of Ireland as well, is about the gravitational pull of London and the South East more generally and how you deal with that, how you cope with that. Dan, how much politically have people in the North East defined themselves against London and against the idea of a sort of, I mean, to use the sort of the terminology that we're all so familiar with now, the idea of a metropolitan elite? Well, as I said, I think it's soured of late because we've lost that kind of reciprocity between the two places and we've lost that kind of reciprocity between the two places. And we've come to see ourselves more as a sort of benighted province of a distant imperial capital. And if you take the long view of the south of England's dominance,
在19世纪中期曾有一些计划在曼彻斯特建立一个替代议会。但如今这种可能性不大了，尽管在这个大流行时期出现了一些波澜，安迪·伯恩姆（Andy Burnham）在一系列南北冲突中成为了北方的旗手，这在几个月前浮出水面，现在似乎又平息了一些，伦敦通过白厅和威斯敏斯特等重新确立了自己的地位。但除了工业革命那个短暂时期局势略有扭转之外，那是我认为北方占据统治地位的唯一时期。我认为这很不寻常，不是吗？在欧洲比较的背景下，这非常不寻常，因为如果你看看葡萄牙（里斯本和波尔图）、西班牙（马德里、巴塞罗那、毕尔巴鄂、塞维利亚）、法国（里昂、马赛）、德国（许多城市，当然，因为德国直到1870、1871年才统一）。但英格兰非常不寻常，我认为。而且这在我们的政治上造成了扭曲，正如汤姆所称的那样，一切都被吸入了“大当家”之中。
and I suppose you can read it in that, London's dominance, they've seen off any threat to its power several times in history, or they've been the springboard for, frankly, attacks on the North. You know, if you stand back from it and think about, you know, I've always been interested in the harrying of the North in the 11th century by the Normans, and then you've got the Wars of the Roses after that, the Reformation, you know, when the North was the stronghold of um catholicism the civil war had a north-south dimension the jacobite rebellions also then you've got peter
把镜头稍微拉宽一点，也许回到工业革命之前，威廉·里奇（William Ritchie）提出了一个关于约克（York）的问题。为什么约克从未崛起为与伦敦相抗衡的枢纽？作为一个罗马和维京首都、宗教中心、最大郡的首府和内河港口，所以，你知道，当时甚至有传闻要将上议院迁往
lew and the chartist rebellion and all those sort of things which were kind of fermented in the north but pretty pretty swiftly dealt with and uh and put down and uh, you know, from the perspective of 2021, London in the South East presides as it ever has, you know, it's seen off any of those threats to its dominance, really. And I can't see much changing on that front, frankly. Because, in a sense, no matter how many government departments or museums or whatever you shuffle around the rest of the country it is the kind of brutal fact of geography that and i suppose of kind of cultural you know the cumulative effect of centuries and centuries of of political and cultural power that makes London so challengingly preponderant.
约克，那是一个疯狂的鲍里斯计划，令人惊讶的是它似乎已经烟消云散了。我们可以从他的埃塞克斯（Essex）机场飞到那里。但约克确实拥有，我想——我不记得了——某位著名历史学家将其描述为不列颠的天然首都。所以，丹，作为一个南方的软脚虾，你对约克有什么看法？是的，它是。这是一个非常愉快的地方。尽管，你知道，约克确实有一个庞大的工人阶级社区，围绕着铁路、巧克力制作和所有这类事情。
Yeah, yeah. There was a briefish period from, let's say, about 1700 to 1914 when the North almost became preeminent in England because of the, again, going back to geology, it found this enormous mineral wealth under its feet. And, you know, places like the northeast of England, Newcastle became the sort of dallas or dubai of the 18th century because it controlled this vastly uh important commodity coal fuel power but that didn't last um you know manchester likewise is the center of the industrial revolution cotton spinning and all
但我认为，这里再次存在一个残酷的地理事实：伦敦距离欧洲的那个繁荣核心、欧洲的繁荣地带要近得多。我认为这个地带从英格兰东南部延伸穿过低地国家、莱茵兰，穿过——你知道——进入意大利北部。在至少一千年的时间里，这里一直是欧洲经济中最繁荣、最具动态的部分。而且，你知道，泰晤士河或多或少正对着它。所以，仅仅是这种临近的因素，对于伦敦和东南部的成长来说，就如同英吉利海峡的宽度对于不列颠的安全一样具有决定性作用。
the rest of it there were some plans in the mid-19th century to create an alternative parliament in Manchester. But there's not much chance of that these days, although there's some stirrings through this pandemic period in the figure of Andy Burnham being a sort of flag bearer for the North in that same sequence of North versus South clashes, which did emerge a month or two ago and seems to have subsided again a little bit and London's
你知道，人们有时会说，英国政治史无名列前茅的稳定性是因为我们宪法的荣耀和所有这些我认为很重要的东西，但我确实认为英吉利海峡的宽度具有相当决定性的作用。这意味着拿破仑、威廉皇帝和所有这类威胁根本无法轻易行军到这里，也就是“权杖之岛”（scepter'd isle）的因素。所以地理再次被证明是命运。我想我们需要一个——我可能会去吃个司康饼（scone）。丹，我猜你想吃个“scoon”（另一种发音）或者随便什么。
reasserted itself through Whitehall and Westminster and so on. But other than that brief kind of industrial revolution period when the tables were turned slightly that's been the only time I think when the North has been pre-eminent. And I think that's unusual isn't it it's very unusual in a comparative european context because if you're
先抹奶油还是先抹果酱？先抹果酱还是先抹奶油？谁知道呢？我们在中场休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦的固定栏目。
if you look at you know portugal you're lisbon and porto spain madrid barcelona bilbao seville france you know lyon marseille germany lots of cities, because, of course, Germany wasn't unified until 1870, 71. But England is very unusual, I think. And that's distorting on our politics personally, that everything is sucked into this, as Tom calls it, the great when. Just broadening the camera a bit and maybe going back before the Industrial Revolution, there's a question from William Ritchie who mentions York. And why did York never emerge as a rival hub to London a Roman and Viking capital ecclesiastical centre capital of the largest county and river port so you know and there was talk wasn't there of moving the house of lords to
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎从遛惠比特犬（whippets）回来继续收听《历史的剩余》，我们正在谈论南北差距。现在我们来谈谈——我们已经处理了一些比较琐碎的问题，让我们进入真正的实质内容。汤姆·沃茨（Tom Watts）提出了一个问题，他说：一天当中不同时间吃的饭菜，名字怎么这么乱？丹，早餐、午餐（lunch）、茶点（tea）。我弄错了吗？我想是早餐、正餐（dinner）、茶点，对吧？
York that was a kind of mad Boris plan that seems to have bitten the dust, surprisingly. We can fly there from his S3 airport. But York does have, I think, I can't remember, some famous historian described it as the natural capital of Britain. So what's your take on York, Dan, as a southern softies to you, I guess? Yes, it is. It's a very pleasant place. Although, you know, I did have a large working class community at York, centered around the railways and chocolate making and all that sort of thing.
哦，是的，当然是。我在说什么？我连自己的心思都不知道了。好吧，我想是正餐或午餐。你从来不用“lunch”这个词吗？我用，但我每次说去吃个午餐时，总觉得自己有点矫情。是的。好吧，午餐（luncheon），那你就像约翰·梅杰（John Major）了，不是吗？但“tea”，我认为关键在于，晚餐是“tea”。
But I think there's just the brute fact of geography, again, that London is just that much closer to that kind of European core, core prosperous zone of Europe, which I think extends from Southeast England through the Low Countries, through the Rhineland, through, you know, into Northern Italy. That has always been for at least a thousand years, the most prosperous dynamic part of economic part of Europe. And, you know, the Thames faces it more or less. And so just that proximity factor, was as decisive for you know the growth of London the southeast as the width of
是的。我是个吃“tea”的人。我从小就是吃“tea”长大的。不过我去上学时，老实说其他人吃的都是“dinner”，因为我上的是寄宿学校。难道不是“supper”吗？好吧，那才叫矫情。
the English Channel was to the security of of Britain um you know people sometimes say you know the unique stability of the British political history is because of the glories of our constitution and all that sort of thing which I think is important but I do think the width of the English channel has been pretty decisive it meant that Napoleon and the Kaiser and all those sorts of threats just couldn't march over here very easily the the scepter dial factor so geography uh yet again proving to be destiny I think we need a. I might go and have a scone. Dan, I expect you want a scoon or whatever it is.
不，那是大都市作风。你说的“supper”是指一碗脆坚果玉米片之类的东西吗？不，他有多道菜。是谁说过，一个英国人一开口就不免招另一个英国人鄙视，这是因为——因为我猜，这也是因为——
Cream over jam. Jam over cream. Who knows? We will see you after this break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
阶级问题与区域差异交织在一起的方式。而且我想，丹，你会觉得南方继续施加其首要地位的方式之一，就是它诱使北方人来到南方并在克拉珀姆（Clapham）居住。是的，好吧，这一直是19世纪英国统治阶级所受批判的一部分，当然，他们不想去——
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back from exercising your whippets to The the rest is history and we're talking about the north-south divide now let's talk about the you know we've dealt with some of the sort of more trivial questions let's get to the real substance tom watts has asked the question he says what is going on with different names for meals eaten at different times of day. Dan, breakfast, lunch, tea. Am I wrong? I think it's breakfast, dinner, tea, isn't it?
在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来，从遛完小灰狗回来继续收听《历史余音》，我们正在讨论南北差距，现在我们来谈谈……你知道的，我们已经处理了一些比较琐碎的问题，现在让我们进入真正的实质内容。汤姆·沃茨提出了一个问题，他说，一天中不同时间吃的饭菜，为什么会有不同的名称？丹，早餐、午餐、茶点。我错了吗？我觉得应该是早餐、正餐（dinner）、茶点（tea），对吧？
Oh yeah, of course it is. What am I saying? I don't even know my own mind. Well, I think dinner or lunch. Do you never use the word lunch? I do, but I always feel slightly effete when I talk about going for a spot of lunch. Yes. Well, luncheon, I suppose. Luncheon, you'd be John Major then, wouldn't you? But tea, I think the key thing is the evening meal, isn't it, is tea.
哦，对，当然是这样。我都在说什么啊？我都语无伦次了。嗯，我觉得是正餐（dinner）还是午餐（lunch）。你从来不用“午餐（lunch）”这个词吗？我用，但每次说到去吃点午餐时，总觉得自己有点矫情。是的。好吧，午膳（luncheon），我想是的。午膳，那你就像约翰·梅杰了，对吧？不过我觉得关键的晚饭是茶点（tea），对吧，就是tea。
Yes. I'm a tea man. I was brought up with tea. Though when I went to school, everybody else had dinner, to be fair, because I went to a boarding school. Is it not supper? Well, that is a feat.
是的。我是个习惯叫tea的人。我从小就是叫tea。不过我去上学时，老实说，其他所有人都叫dinner，因为我上的是寄宿学校。难道不叫supper吗？嗯，那可真够矫情的。
No, it's metropolitan and by supper you mean a ball of crunchy nut cornflakes or something no he has multiple courses who who is it said that that it's impossible for an englishman to open his mouth and not be despised by another englishman because it's because i guess that that also what's feeding in here is is the way in which other Englishmen. Because I guess also what's feeding in here is the way in which issues of class mix with regional
不，那是大都市的叫法，你说的supper是指一碗脆坚果玉米片之类的东西吗？不，他有多个菜。是谁说的来着？……说一个英国人一张嘴，就免不了被另一个英国人鄙视？因为我想这也是因为阶级问题与地区差异交织在一起的方式。
variations. And I guess, Dan, you would feel that one of the ways that the South continues to exert its primacy is that it kind of seduces people from the north into coming down to the south and kind of living in clapham yes well that was always as a critique of the ruling classes of the 19th century in britain certainly that they they didn't want to get
而且我想，丹，你会觉得南方继续保持其统治地位的方式之一，就是它诱使北方人南下，来到南方并住在克拉珀姆。是的，这在19th世纪英国统治阶级的批判中一直是这样，当然，他们不想……
their their sons didn't want to get their hands dirty and they wanted to turn themselves into englishmen like mr bingley and all that sort of thing in jnos that they uh they they quickly left the north as fast as they could but i think the rp thing's really interesting because it is said that um robert peel and william gladstone both lancastrian prime ministers had a i think peel more so had a proper lanky sheer sort of uh twang or burr to his accent but all that was ironed out in the course of the 19th century through boarding schools and so on, and then reinforced by the BBC, I guess, from the 1920s onwards.
他们的儿子不想弄脏双手，他们想把自己变成像宾利先生那样的英国人，诸如此类。总之，呃，他们，他们，他们尽快地离开了北方，但我认为标准英语这事真的很有趣，因为据说，呃，罗伯特·皮尔和威廉·格莱斯顿这两位兰开夏出身的首相，都有——我觉得皮尔更是如此——他的口音里有一种地道的兰开夏腔调，或者说卷舌音和鼻音。但所有这些都在19世纪通过寄宿学校等方式被逐渐抹平了，然后，我想，从20世纪20年代开始，又通过BBC得到了强化。
It smoothed out all the wrinkles. I definitely think that's right. I mean, I remember you might know this book, Classes and Cultures by Ross McKibben, Dan, in which he basically argues that england only got a sort of uniform english culture from the 1920s onwards because of things like the bbc because that erased the differences of dialect and class and and of regional culture by creating a national culture that hitherto had not existed at all. So in other words, you know, if you were growing up in the late 19th century
它抚平了所有的褶皱。我绝对认为这没错。我是说，丹，我记得你可能知道这本书，罗斯·麦基宾写的《阶级与文化》，他在书中基本上认为，英国只是从20世纪20年代开始，才通过BBC之类的事物获得了一种统一的英国文化，因为BBC通过创造一种此前根本不存在的国家文化，抹平了方言、阶级以及地区文化的差异。所以换句话说，你知道，如果你在19世纪末长大，
and you went to the music hall or to hear a comedian or something, you wouldn't get all, if you were in Liverpool and you went to London, you wouldn't get it. You wouldn't get the dialect, you wouldn't get the references. And then actually the idea of an English culture was only created in the 20th century. And as you say, it basically became a southern culture, sort of with northerners dragged
你去音乐厅听喜剧演员表演什么的，你是不会懂的，如果你在利物浦然后去了伦敦，你是听不懂的。你听不懂方言，你听不懂那些梗。所以实际上，英国文化的理念直到20世纪才被创造出来。正如你所说，它基本上变成了一种南方文化，某种程度上把北方人当作
on for comic relief or sort of wilfred pickles style sort of yeah you know amusing character stuff but dominic does it i mean it goes back much further than that doesn't it i mean at least to the 14th century when you are starting when english is starting to become the language of government and you're starting to get the sense that the the triangle of London Oxford and Cambridge is the kind of English that properly should be spoken and I mean it's really telling that Chaucer who's the great first great poet of that kind of style of English Dan I think I'm right in the Reeves tale there are kind of two Geordie students and Chaucer mimics what they sound like to a southern
搞笑的调剂，或者说威尔弗雷德·皮克尔斯那种风格的、嗯，你知道的，有趣的滑稽角色。不过多米尼克，这事确实——我是说，它的历史要久远得多，不是吗？至少可以追溯到14世纪，当时英语开始成为政府的语言，你开始感觉到，伦敦、牛津和剑桥这个铁三角才是真正应该说的英语。而且很有说明意义的是，乔叟，作为这种风格英语的最初的大诗人和伟大代表，丹，我觉得我没记错的话，在《里夫的故事》里有大约两个乔迪学生，乔叟模仿了他们在南方的
a southerner in the in in the late 14th century yes I'm trying to remember the quote now but it it's it's it's terms that are designed to draw out those peculiarities of northern speech which any kind of northern student will have experienced they went to university and your pal say go on Dan say snooker but it's there already in the 14th century I'm glad we've got him to do it um I mean it's kind of amazing amazing and and that of course is something that um that you see even more in a even more pronounced way in other European countries I guess Italy would be the classic example of the need essentially to create a unitary single language out of,
南方人听来是什么样的，在14世纪后期。是的，我正努力回想那句引文，但它的措辞旨在勾勒出北方口音的那些独特性，任何北方学生在去上大学时都会经历过这种事，你的伙伴会说：“来吧，丹，说‘斯诺克’（snooker）。”但这在14世纪就已经存在了。我很高兴我们请他来表演这个，嗯——我是说，这真是太神奇了，而且这当然是你在其他欧洲国家看到的一种更加明显、更加突出的现象，我想意大利会是一个典型的例子：基本上需要把
I mean, they're called dialects, but basically they're a whole range of patchwork of different languages. So England is, is kind of precocious in that sense of developing a common language that actually can be understood relatively early, perhaps relative to French or to what we now call Italian. And I think on that theme, let's just broaden this out because we've
我是说，它们被称为方言，但基本上它们是一整套不同的语言拼凑体。所以在那种意义上，英国可以说是早熟的，它发展出了一种能够相对较早地被理解的通用语言，也许相对于法语或我们现在所说的意大利语来说是这样的。我想顺着这个主题，我们把它展开讲讲，因为我们
been talking very specifically about England. But I think we can look at the whole question about how do we overemphasise national history at the expense perhaps of regional history? And there's a question here from Mike J., which expresses this very nicely. Many countries have regional divides, most obviously USA, but also many EU countries like Italy again. I'd love to hear your thoughts on what makes the UK split unique. So interestingly, I mean, Mike is talking about the UK. So in England, we've been talking about the North-South divide, and it's generally expressed in that the south is wealthier uh the north is relatively more disadvantaged um in italy now it would be the other way around i guess that's true yeah that is true it's not just true in italy though is it's true in france so i lived for a year in the south of france uh as a student in the 1990s and the
一直非常具体地在谈论英国。但我觉得我们可以探讨这样一个宏观问题：我们是否在某种程度上过分强调了国家历史，而牺牲了地区历史？这里有一个迈克·J.提出的问题，把这一点表达得非常贴切。许多国家都存在地区分歧，最明显的当然是美国，但也有许多欧盟国家，比如意大利。我很想听听你们对英国的分裂有何独特之处的看法。有趣的是，迈克谈到的是英国。所以在英国，我们一直在谈论南北差距，它通常表现为南方更富有，而北方相对更加弱势。但在意大利，情况现在可能恰好相反，我想是这样的吧？没错，确实如此。不过这不仅适用于意大利，对法国也一样。所以我在20世纪90年代曾作为学生在法国南部生活了一年，那里的
southerners in you know in france absolutely loathed and despised paris in the north and their their image was southerners were seen as criminal as lazy as um um as as sort of deceitful uh and northerners were seen as but but as taciturn and all so those things are not dissimilar but of course northerners were richer than southerners so the souttherners were seen as taciturn and all. So those things are not dissimilar. But of course, Northerners were richer than Southerners. So the Southerners were poor and the Northerners were rich in France. So it's slightly different. And Italy, I guess, it's not just North-South, is it? I mean, effectively, as you say, it's multiple nations bolted together in the 19th century.
法国南部的南方人对北方的巴黎简直痛恨之极、鄙视之极，在他们的印象中，南方人被视为罪犯、懒惰、呃……呃……某种程度上是奸诈的；而北方人则被视为……但被视为沉默寡言等等。所以这些情况并非不相似，但当然，北方人比南方人更富有，所以南方人被视为沉默寡言等等。所以这些情况并非不相似。但当然，北方人比南方人更富有。所以法国的南方人穷，北方人富。情况稍微有点不同。至于意大利，我想，这不仅是南北问题，对吧？也就是说，实际上，正如你所说，它是19世纪被拼凑在一起的多个国家。
But the thing about Italy, I guess, in contrast, say, to Britain, in Britain, the North has always been, relatively speaking, poorer. hadrian's wall is built because the north essentially is seen by the romans as not worth conquering whereas in italy um sicily is the great center of greek civilization and south italy and relatively speaking in antiquity the north is seen as as as more backward and that of course then changes with the rise of the Roman Empire. But it's relatively recent that the idea of southern Italy and Sicily is backward comes in. Because even in the Middle Ages, you've got this incredible,
但关于意大利，我想与英国相比，在英国，北方相对而言一直比较穷。哈德良长城之所以修建，主要是因为罗马人认为北方根本不值得征服；而在意大利，西西里是希腊文明的伟大中心，还有意大利南部，而且在古代，相对而言，北方被视为更落后。当然，随着罗马帝国的崛起，这种情况发生了变化。但意大利南部和西西里很落后的这种观念出现得相对较晚。因为即使在中世纪，你也拥有这样一个不可思议的、
in Sicily, this incredible reservoir of Greek, Byzantine, Arab, Frankish fusion. And it's, I'm not sure, I mean, when is it that Sicily becomes, is it the 18th century, comes to become a kind of a backwater relative to the north of Italy? I would say 19th century. I would say 19th century, I think. Dan, what about America? So did northerners, when they went to America,
在西西里，这是一个由希腊、拜占庭、阿拉伯和法兰克文化融合而成的不可思议的宝库。而且我不太确定，我是说，西西里是什么时候变成——是18世纪吗？——相对于意大利北部变成了一个类似死水潭的地方？我会说是19世纪。我会说是19世纪，我想是的。丹，那美国呢？那么北方人去美国的时候，
take their northerness with them? Yes, it's interesting that the patterns of migration, depending on where you came from in the British Isles, were very different. And I've always been interested in the so-called Scots-Irish as this group that went in the kind of hillbilly country of Appalachia, but included within their number a large proportion of border English. And there's a great book by David Hackett Fisher called Albion Seed, which describes how the Cavaliers went to Delaware and the Puritans went to New England and what he calls the borderers, both English and Scots, who were originally transplanted to Ulster and then another hop to America, settled in different parts of the world because, frankly, they had different cultures. They had different religions, different stripes of Protestant Christianity,
他们把北方属性也带过去了吗？是的，有趣的是，根据你来自不列颠群岛的哪个地方，移民模式是非常不同的。我一直对所谓的苏格兰-爱尔兰人很感兴趣，这个群体去了阿巴拉契亚的山民地区，但其中也包含了很大一部分边境英国人。大卫·哈克特·费舍尔有一本很棒的书叫《阿尔比恩的种子》，书中描述了骑士是如何去特拉华州的，清教徒是如何去新英格兰的，以及他所说的边民——包括英国人和苏格兰人，他们最初被移植到阿尔斯特，然后又跳跃了一次来到美国——如何在世界各地不同的地方定居，因为坦率地说，他们有着不同的文化。他们有不同的宗教，不同流派的基督教新教，
but they had different kind of culture. And I've always been fascinated by the kind of feuding Hatfields versus McCoy's ranching culture of the Southern and Western USA was pretty much transplanted from the Anglo-Scottish border reavers, you know, who wouldn't take a backward step, who would persist with these feuds down the centuries between different clans? So, Dan, would you say in the 19th century United States, North and South go to war? I mean, that's that's the ultimate expression of a North-South divide. Is that culturally determined rather than determined by geography, would you say? I think to an extent in the way that it was perceived as the kind of gallant martial races of the southern USA
但他们有着不同的文化。我一直对美国南部和西部那种世仇不断的哈特菲尔德对麦考伊家族的牧场文化很着迷，这几乎是从盎格鲁-苏格兰边境的强盗那里移植过来的，你知道的，他们绝不退让半步，在几个世纪里不同家族之间一直延续着这些世仇。所以，丹，你会说在19世纪的美国，北方和南方走向战争——我的意思是，那是南北差距的终极表现——你会说这是由文化决定的，而不是由地理决定的吗？我想在某种程度上是的，从某种方式来看，它被视为美国南部勇敢的尚武种族，
and that martial culture, I think, which was a big part of the southern identity, did emerge, I think, from a particular part of the British Isles and the fact that, and it goes back to our point about if you study regional history, you realise how different it can be because the perspective of English history from the northeast of England is one of centuries of border warfare in comparison to the south of England,
那种尚武文化——我认为这是南方认同感的一个重要部分——确实是从不列颠群岛的某个特定地区演变而来的。而且，这回到了我们之前的观点，如果你研究地区历史，你就会意识到它可以是多么的不同，因为从英格兰东北部的视角来看，英格兰东北部充满着几个世纪的边境战争，相比之下，英格兰南部
which is all pretty tranquil and swords have been beaten into plough shares pretty early, whereas we're still fighting off the Scots well into the 1700s. So that was a more important fact of life that shaped the culture and in my view shaped the kind of macho martial traditions in the northeast of england that still persist to my in my view uh as a result of that again another factor of geography that it was a borderland and and like i said that was also transplanted to the southern usa um in theth, 18th and 19th centuries. Dan can I ask you a question that picks up on something Tom mentioned earlier which is class.
则要平静得多，剑很早就被铸成了犁头，而我们在18世纪还一直在抵御苏格兰人。所以这是塑造了该文化的一个更重要的生活事实，在我看来，它塑造了英格兰东北部那种至今仍然存在的、好勇斗狠的尚武传统——在我看来，作为地理的另一个因素，它曾是一个边境地带，就像我说的，这也在18世纪和19世纪被移植到了美国南部。丹，我能问你一个顺着汤姆刚才提到的话题——也就是阶级——的问题吗？
Northerners particularly in the 20th century has come to sort of stand in for working class hasn't it? So particularly in the 1930s I think in the depression and then in the 1960s obviously when you had kind of new wave cinema and you had the Beatles and you had this sort of Harold Wilson becoming Prime Minister, northerness, and Coronation Street, most famously, I suppose, or the novels of Catherine Cookson, northerness has just become sort of almost slightly lazily equated with this sort of working class authenticity and grit. Is that a 20th century thing or does that have deeper roots i think it's got much deeper roots and you and often this north south thing why it matters is because um they're kind of freighted with meaning aren't they and um kind of value judgments about
北方人，特别是20世纪以来，在某种程度上已经成为了工人阶级的代名词，不是吗？因此，特别是在20世纪30年代的大萧条时期，然后在20世纪60年代，显然当时有了新浪潮电影，有了披头士乐队，有了哈罗德·威尔逊当选首相，北方特色——以及最著名的《加冕街》，或者凯瑟琳·库克森的小说——北方特色几乎有些懒惰地等同于这种工人阶级的真实性和坚韧性。这是一种20世纪的现象，还是有着更深厚的根源？我认为它有着深得多的根源，而且这种南北现象之所以重要，是因为它们被赋予了各种含义，不是吗？它们带有关于
northerners being these noble spartan you know honest to goodness really friendly as opposed to um well well when john vanbrugh came up north to to build seaton delaval hall in the 18th century he said i much preferred up here to the tame and sneaking south and he was just southern he says they're all hearty honest to goodness you know hard-working chaps up here and i much prefer their company and you see that whether it's true or not about friendliness and honesty and all those sorts of things but i think the industrial culture of the northeast was that the north in general was certainly decisive because it wasn't as the economy wasn't as diverse as the south and there was a lot of people who were in the same boat or um you could take county durham in 1900 about um 40 or
北方人是高尚的斯巴达人、诚实可靠、极其友好，相比之下，嗯……当约翰·范布鲁在18世纪来到北方建造西顿代拉瓦尔庄园时，他说：“我远比喜欢温顺且卑怯的南方人更喜欢北方。”他自己就是南方人，他说：“这儿的人都热情、诚实、靠谱、勤劳，我更喜欢和他们在一起。”无论关于友好、诚实之类的事情是否属实，你都能看到这一点。但我认为东北部的工业文化——或者说整个北方——绝对是决定性的，因为它的经济不像南方那样多元化，有很多人都处于相同的处境，或者说，你可以拿1900年的达勒姆郡来说，大约
50 percent of all the adult males of working age were coal miners. So it was an extraordinary kind of monoculture where everyone had the same experiences, expectations. They were all doing the same sorts of work, whereas the rest of the country, Birmingham was the city of a thousand trades and all that sort of thing, and the South was very diverse. That sense of all being in it together was a big feature of the North and its economy and therefore its identity, I think. Well, on the issue of class and region, we've already touched on football, but we've got a question about another sport from Tides of History. Excellent Twitter account on the history of the
40%到50%的适龄成年男性都是煤矿工人。所以这是一种非同寻常的单一文化，每个人都有着相同的经历和期望。他们都在做着同样的工作，而相比之下，全国其他地方，伯明翰是一座千行百业的城市诸如此类，南方则非常多元化。这种大家同舟共济的感觉是北方及其经济的一个重要特征，因此也是其身份认同的一个重要特征，我认为是这样的。好吧，关于阶级和地区的问题，我们已经谈到了足球，但我们收到了来自“历史浪潮”（Tides of History）关于另一项运动的问题。这是一个关于
labour party um which asks our perceptions of rugby league and rugby union symbolic of the historical north-south divide league seen as working class industrial but parochial union as middle class white collar and embedded in the establishment um either of you rugby fans i'm not so i don't know anything about rugby at all but um very happy about cricket there's a lot of truth in this isn't it but of course it it misses you know some of rugby union's biggest hotbeds places like gloucester where it's very much working class game so the sort of stereotype sort of does miss something but i guess there's a seed of truth there isn't it dan that rugby
工党历史的优秀推特账号，它提问：“我们对联盟式橄榄球（Rugby League）和联合式橄榄球（Rugby Union）的看法，是否象征着历史上南北差距？联盟式橄榄球被视为工人阶级的、工业化的，但有些狭隘；联合式橄榄球则被视为中产阶级的、白领的，并且根植于当权派之中。你们俩谁是橄榄球迷吗？我不是，所以我对橄榄球一无所知，不过……我对板球非常高兴。”这里面有很大一部分是事实，不是吗？但当然它也忽略了，你知道的，联盟式橄榄球的一些最大大本营，比如格洛斯特，那里的橄榄球在很大程度上是工人阶级的运动。所以这种刻板印象确实遗漏了一些东西，但我猜其中确实包含了一点真相，不是吗，丹，联盟式
league is seen as sort of rugby league is gritty and authentic and rugby union is kind of will carling yeah i think it's shaking that that slightly poncy reputation off these days isn't it rugby union and compared to rugby league i mean um but it's interesting that the the uh it's what rugby of any code wasn't uniformly popular across the north of England. It's never really taken off in the northeast of England, for example. Why? Well, Harry Pearson, who's a great writer on the northeast non-league scene, I'm paraphrasing his argument slightly, but he more or less made the point that the Geordies didn't need to prove how tough they were.
橄榄球被视为那种坚韧和真实的，而联合式橄榄球则是像威尔·卡林那样……是的，我觉得它现在正在摆脱那种稍微有些自命不凡的声誉，不是吗？联合式橄榄球与联盟式橄榄球相比，我的意思是……但有趣的是，呃……橄榄球——无论哪种规则——在英格兰北部并不是普遍受欢迎的。例如，它在英格兰东北部从未真正流行起来。为什么？嗯，哈里·皮尔森是东北部非联赛领域的一位伟大作家，我稍微转述一下他的观点，但他或多或少地指出，乔迪人不需要向别人证明他们有多顽强。
So there was no need for outlets like rugby, which is fundamentally about men showing off about how hard they are. What Northeastern working class men was an outlet for their artistry and their skill and their athleticism, which is hence why we produce some of the greatest footballers, Beardsley, Gascoigne, Waddle, et cetera, et cetera. That's where they came from. I think it's an interesting theory. And fundamentally, football, I think we can all agree, is just a better and more exciting game than rugby. So it's always good.
所以根本不需要像橄榄球这样的宣泄口，橄榄球本质上是关于男人炫耀自己有多强悍的。东北部工人阶级男人所需要的是一个展示他们的艺术性、技巧和运动能力的宣泄口，这也是为什么我们培养出了一些最伟大的足球运动员：比尔兹利、加斯科因、瓦德尔等等，等等。这就是他们的出身。我认为这是一个有趣的理论。归根结底，足球，我想我们都可以同意，只是一项比橄榄球更好、更激昂的运动。所以它总是好的。
Yeah, yeah, it is. But obviously, it's not as exciting as cricket. And cricket, the national sport of England, is, of course, a sport that is played equally in north and south and uh you know if you think about um surrey playing yorkshire that's one of the great sporting pressures 27 people no millions following millions following from from the comfort of their sitting room i think cricket is is is the closest we've got to a genuinely classless game in england because it is the summer game of got to a genuinely classless game in England
是的，是的，确实如此。但显然，它没有板球那么激动人心。而板球作为英格兰的国球，当然是一项在南北方都同等受欢迎的运动，而且，你知道的，如果你想到萨里对阵约克郡，那是伟大的体育对决之一。27个人——不，是数以百万计的人在舒适的客厅里关注着。我认为板球是我们所拥有的、最接近真正无阶级之分的运动，在英格兰，因为它是一项……最接近真正无阶级的运动，
because it is the summer game of the coalfields, cricket, without question. And there was a great footage of when Ben Stokes scored the winning runs and it was a big crowd of Newcastle supporters at White Hart Lane watching this on screens. And when he scores the winning runs, the whole crowd go mental. In a way, I don't think they would do for, you know, England rugby union team. And it is, it's whole, it's popularities across the whole of England,
因为它是煤矿工人的夏季运动，毫无疑问。当本·斯托克斯（Ben Stokes）打出制胜一分时，有很棒的录像显示，怀特哈特巷聚集了一大群纽卡斯尔联队的球迷，在屏幕上观看这一幕。当他打出制胜一分时，全场观众都疯狂了。这种狂热，我觉得他们对英格兰联合式橄榄球国家队是不会有的。而且它在整个英格兰的普及度是跨越阶级的，
across classes, and the way that neither football nor rugby really can say that. Brilliant. So cricket's the best. I'm glad you're on that. Dominic, have you got another question for us? I do. I want to ask now, somebody asked and I can't. Oh yeah, somebody somebody where is he? Somebody called Taff Alistair Taff, yes
这种普及度是足球或橄榄球都无法真正宣称的。太棒了。所以板球是最好的。我很高兴你能这么说。多米尼克，你还有别的问题要问我们吗？有的。我现在想问一个问题，有人问过，但我记不清了……噢，是的，有人……那个人是谁？一个叫塔夫·阿拉斯泰尔·塔夫（Alistair Taff）的人，是的。
Alistair Taff says, aptly named, he asks about Wales he says, where does Wales fit in the North-South divide or do you just exclude it because it's not England or he says, controversially would you incorporate it into the South? I don't think many people would incorporate it into the South. But do you think
阿拉斯泰尔·塔夫说——名字起得很贴切——他问到了关于威尔士的问题。他说：“威尔士在南北差距中处于什么位置？还是说你们只是把它排除了，因为它不是英格兰？”或者他说：“更具争议的是，你们会把它并入南方吗？”我想没多少人会把它并入南方。但你认为
there's a sort of commonality between Wales and the north of England, Dan? I think so. Politically, I think there's a really interesting point that, again, I mentioned James Hawes's book recently, and he's got this useful way of framing this as Outer Britain, which is basically anything north of the Seven Wash sort of line. He's got this line between about 1880 and about 2015. Oh, we'll put it a bit later than that. Up until 2015, Outer Britain coalesced politically against the southeast and up until 2015 that was known as the labour party basically because the labour party's strength
威尔士和英格兰北部之间有一种共同性吗，丹？我想是的。在政治上，我觉得有一个非常有趣的观点，我最近也提到了詹姆斯·霍斯的那本书，他有一个很有用的框架，把它称为“外英国”（Outer Britain），基本上就是塞文河-沃什河一线以北的任何地方。他划定了这条线，大约在1880年到2015年之间。噢，我们把它定得晚一点。直到2015年，外英国在政治上联合起来对抗东南部。直到2015年，这基本上被称为工党，因为工党的力量
was based on wales northern england and scotland and that was a useful counterbalance against the tory southeast which was pretty impregnably tory from about 1886 onwards. And that kind of shared industrial base led to a shared political culture in the industrial part, certainly of Wales, Northern England and Scotland. Then I guess there's a big north-south divide within Wales as well, isn't there? Yeah. Yes. I mean, I think also what's interesting about Wales is we also haven't talked about East Anglia very much.
立足于威尔士、英格兰北部和苏格兰，这是对托利党控制的东南部的一个有用的制衡。从1886年左右开始，东南部就几乎是托利党的铁盘。这种共享的工业基础，在威尔士、英格兰北部和苏格兰的工业地区，带来了一种共享的政治文化。然后我想威尔士内部也有很大的南北差距，不是吗？是的。是的。我的意思是，同样有趣的是，关于威尔士，我们也没有怎么谈论东盎格利亚。
And actually one of the kind of the earliest historical documents that we have from Britain, which is Gildas, who's, Dominic, very like you, kind of Daily Mail. Despairing of the nation, ranting about the state of the nation. To Gildas write articles with the headline, The Great Betrayal. Why, oh why, why, oh why have the Romans left? And he does this after the Romans have withdrawn. And he is talking about a divided Britain, but his division is East and West. So he is saying that that's the division.
实际上，我们从英国获得的最早的历史文献之一，吉尔达斯——多米尼克，这非常像你，有点像《每日邮报》的风格：对国家感到绝望，痛斥国家的现状。吉尔达斯写文章的大标题是《巨大的背叛》。为什么，哦，为什么，为什么，哦，为什么罗马人要离开？他在罗马人撤走之后写下了这些。他在谈论一个分裂的英国，但他的划分是东西之分。所以他是说，这才是分歧所在。
And it's generally assumed that he's talking about what we would call the Britons and the invading Anglo-Saxons who were coming across the North Sea. But it's not absolutely apparent that that is what he's talking about. It may be that he's expressing a kind of sense of a fundamental divide that existed in maybe the province of Britannia, maybe before Britannia, that is certainly to Gildas as significant as the idea of a North-South divide. But I think that is something that's been lost. I don't think anyone would really think of that now. Although, you know, the East-West division in England is an interesting one, because when in UKIP's heyday, their support tended to be concentrated right on the East Coast, didn't it? Places like Lincolnshire and Essex and places like that,
人们普遍认为他谈论的是我们所说的布立吞人和穿越北海入侵的盎格鲁-撒克逊人。但这并不是绝对显而易见的，他谈的就是这个。他可能是在表达一种存在于不列颠行省、甚至可能是不列颠之前的根本分歧感，这在吉尔达斯看来，绝对不亚于南北差距的理念。但我认为那是已经失落的东西。现在不会有人真正这么想了。尽管，你知道的，英格兰的东西分歧很有趣，因为在英国独立党（UKIP）的全盛时期，他们的支持者往往高度集中在东海岸，不是吗？像林肯郡、埃塞克斯郡之类的地方，
that kind of North Sea. I went through Newark once, Dan, and they had a UKIP shop, which is not the kind of thing. UKIP banners and badges and UKIP reading material. I mean, obviously, Tom, you'd be very unfamiliar with this, with your metropolitan ways. No, obviously. you kept reading material i mean obviously you know tom you'd be very unfamiliar with this with your metropolitan uh ways no i've obviously uh the people who knew it clearly liked it i mean i mean that's an interesting thing isn't it this the whole with you talk you made down what i
那种北海沿岸。丹，我曾经去过纽瓦克一次，那里有一家英国独立党商店，这可不是那种……英国独立党的横幅、徽章和英国独立党读物。我的意思是，显而易见，汤姆，你对这种带着大都市作风的东西会非常陌生。不，显然……英国独立党读物——我的意思是，显而易见，你知道的，汤姆，你对这种带着大都市作风的东西会非常陌生。不，显然……那些了解它的人显然很喜欢它。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的现象，不是吗？整个……你刚才提到了一点，丹，我认为这是一个
thought was a a really interesting point about you know this sort of idea of the european corridor if you like stretching from you know from london to, I don't know, Milan or wherever. And obviously Europe and our relationship with Europe and the idea of the North-South divide, they're very tightly enmeshed now, aren't they? I mean, I remember very vividly, it's really stuck in my mind a few months after the Brexit referendum referendum i'm talking to some academics and one of them saying i wish the bbc would stop going to the north of england interviewing all these people who don't know anything and i thought there you have you know there in one sentence is the sort of key to so much so many of our current discontents so i was going to follow up on that that one of the things that's happened recently with the growth of kind of virtual communications is that actually that sense of geographically based divisions has slightly become confused because I would I would guess that kind of remain essential is London and university towns, essentially.
非常有趣的观点，关于这种欧洲走廊的理念，如果你愿意的话，从伦敦一直延伸到……我不知道，米兰或其他地方。显然，欧洲、我们与欧洲的关系以及南北差距的理念，现在紧密地交织在一起，不是吗？我的意思是，我记得非常清楚，深深地印在我的脑海里，在英国脱欧公投几个月后，我跟一些学者交谈，其中一个人说：“我希望BBC能停止去英格兰北部采访所有这些什么都不懂的人。”当时我想，瞧，你在一句话里就找到了我们当前诸多不满的症结所在。所以我要接着这个话题说下去，最近随着虚拟通信的发展，发生的事情之一是，实际上这种基于地理的分裂感变得有点模糊了，因为我猜，坚定的留欧派核心基本上是伦敦和大学城。
I mean, it's those are the absolute hotbeds. It's your triangle tom london oxford cambridge isn't it i mean yeah it it is but it's also canterbury for instance um i guess you know wherever there are large quantities of students um and and so that i think has slightly scrambled the the stereotypical regionally based divisions but i think that's a good point and dan there is an interesting thing, isn't there, which is that Sunderland and the Northeast, maybe more generally, has come to stand for Brexit in people's minds.
我的意思是，这些绝对是温床。这就是你的铁三角，汤姆：伦敦、牛津、剑桥，不是吗？我的意思是，是的，确实如此，但它也是坎特伯雷，比如说，呃……我想，无论哪里有大量的学生，都是如此。所以我觉得这稍微打乱了那种刻板印象中基于地区的划分。但我认为这是一个很好的观点，丹，有一个有趣的现象，不是吗？那就是桑德兰和东北部，也许更广泛地说，在人们的心目中已经成为了脱欧的代名词。
So people, I think partly because they announced the first results, but also because of Nissan. So often in sort of Remainer iconography, they point to the Northeast and they say, you know, these benighted dupes who have voted for their own economic self-immolation. And it's the North East that they always sort of that is always produced as exhibit A. Do you think Newcastle voted Remain, didn't it? Exactly, yeah.
所以人们，我认为一部分是因为他们宣布了第一批结果，但也因为日产汽车。因此，在留欧派的符号体系中，他们经常指向东北部，并说：“瞧，这些无知的傻瓜投票支持了他们自己的经济自焚。”而东北部总是被他们当作A号展品拿出来。你觉得纽卡斯尔投的是留欧吧？确实是的。
When everyone points to the north as the Brexit thing, that's where it was born and its strength was. Leeds, Liverpool, Manchester, Newcastle, all the big metropolises of the north were solidly remain. This is where basically most of the middle classes live, or particularly the public sector c sector salaria we might call them tend to be concentrated whereas small town northern england hasn't really seen the benefits of this supposed golden age you know since since the 1970s and it's still pretty disgruntled and
当所有人都把北方指为脱欧发生的地方时，那正是脱欧诞生和力量所在的地方。利兹、利物浦、曼彻斯特、纽卡斯尔，所有北方的这些大都会，都坚决支持留欧。这里基本上是大部分中产阶级居住的地方，或者特别是我们所谓的公共部门C级受薪阶层往往集中的地方，而小镇类型的英格兰北部并没有真正看到这种所谓的黄金时代带来的好处，你知道的，自20世纪70年代以来一直是这样，它仍然相当心怀不满，并且
there was a lot of how could they be so ungrateful to sunderland when they voted it was it wasn't it it was i think it was about 60 40 wasn? So I shouldn't assume that it was a consensus position by any means. But still, I think it is the smaller towns, and people from Sunderland won't like me describing Sunderland. I was about to say, TV's Jonathan Wilson, who we... Oh, that'd be hell on. Mr Sunderland, who I used to play football with, he would be outraged by this sort
有很多人在想，他们怎么能对桑德兰如此忘恩负义呢？当它投票时……不是吗？我想当时大约是60对40，对吧？所以我不应该认为这绝对是一个共识立场。不过，我认为依然是那些小镇，而且桑德兰人不会喜欢我这样形容桑德兰。我正想说，电视上的乔纳森·威尔逊，我们……哦，那可就糟了。桑德兰先生，我以前跟他一起踢过足球，他对这种言论会感到愤怒的。而且，丹，我的意思是……对像我这样的人来说，纽卡斯尔、桑德兰、蒂赛德的口音和身份认同，你知道的，这都属于东北部，不是吗？但显然，事实是你拥有这些河流，甚至在这么短的距离内，地区身份认同也是极其强烈的，难道不是吗？
of talk and and and Dan I mean you know to someone like me the the accents and the identities of Newcastle Sunderland Teesside it's all you know it's all kind of northeast isn't it but obviously the fact that you've got these rivers and even in such a short space regional identities are incredibly strong are they not they are and i think you always look to rivers rivers and railway lines and particularly the watersheds of rivers because i i've i've described the main accent dividing line in the northeast as the beetroot line which is basically follows the watershed dividing line between the rivers tyne and weir if you know the northeast comes out of the coast of whitburn kind of heads diagonally southwest anyone from north of that line would pronounce the word beetroot like i'm pronouncing it i
它们确实很强烈，而且我认为你总是会关注河流、铁路线，尤其是河流的分水岭。因为我曾把东北部的主要口音分界线描述为“甜菜根线”（beetrate line），它基本上沿著泰恩河和韦尔河之间的分水岭分界线延伸。如果你了解东北部的话，它从惠特本的海岸延伸出来，大致呈对角线向西南方向延伸。这条线以北的任何人，对“beetroot”（甜菜根）这个词的发音都跟我一样，我
correctly anyone from the northeast from south of that line would it's slightly elongated draw it'd be more like bait road that that's. It's immediately detectable in North East years. You just ask them to say that word and you can place them north or south of that line. And the history of parochialism, I think, has been a massive feature of English history and not getting on with your neighbours. Yeah, not getting on with your neighbours.
发得很标准。而东北部这条线以南的任何人，则会拖长音，听起来更像是“bait-road”。这在东北部人的耳朵里是立刻就能听出来的。你只要让他们说那个词，你就能判断他们是在这条线的北边还是南边。而且地方狭隘主义的历史，我认为一直是英格兰历史的一个巨大特征，也就是和邻居合不来。是的，和邻居合不来。
That is what this podcast has been all about. And I think that that is the perfect note on which to end it. I mean, I think it's really interesting that this week's subject, basically it's provoked our biggest digital mailbag yet. So apologies if we didn't get to your question, but there'll be lots more opportunities
这就是本期播客的全部内容。我认为这是结束本期的完美音符。我的意思是，我觉得非常有趣的是，本周的主题基本上引发了我们迄今为止最大的数字邮件收件箱。所以如果没有回答到你的问题，请见谅，但未来会有更多机会
to ask us questions. So do please keep tweeting us at TheRestHistory, no is in the Twitter handle, and we'll read out the best of your comments next week. Dan, thanks so much for coming on and being brilliant as ever. Thank you, Tom. Thank you, Dominic.
向我们提问。所以请继续在推特上@TheRestHistory（推特账号里没有is哦）给我们留言，我们下周将宣读你们最好的评论。丹，非常感谢你能来，而且一如既往地精彩。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢你，多米尼克。
Thank you, Dan. Thank you. That was wonderful. And a reminder, we're releasing pods twice a week at the moment, Mondays and Thursdays. So toodle-pip. Ta-ra! Gan-canny! days so toodle pip ta-ra gankani thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening
谢谢你，丹。谢谢。太棒了。顺便提醒一下，我们目前每周发布两次播客，分别在周一和周四。那么，回见啦！再见！走好！谢谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
and access to our chat community please sign up at at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要访问我们的聊天社区，请注册 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。